so as our copic 19 numbers rise so do
concerns from some employees at the va
hospital
again the i-team first reported on
concerns during our first spike in cases
vanessa murphy has been following the
story she's live near the v.a with how
employees are
taking action vanessa
denise two employees here have died of
covid19 and a source says
26 employees have the virus right now
137 have had it since march
a union leader says there are barriers
for employees to get
tested so the union's setting up its own
testing
right outside here now robert olson is
the chief steward of local afge
1224 he says in order for an employee to
get tested at the v.a they must be
showing signs or
symptoms but as we've been reporting
people who are
asymptomatic can spread the virus also
now
the union is working with an outside
agency to provide the testing
this morning through tuesday and
wednesday and then again
in december before christmas
it's not just for our workers but also
for the vets as well
because we don't have the workers here
we can't take care of the vets and
that's what we're here about
olson says the testing is primarily for
union members and their families but
they will not turn away
other employees meaning those who are
not part of the union
a spokesman for the va here says they
follow cdc protocols
and anyone entering the building is
screened now coming up at six we'll have
more for you
on the va's response reporting live
vanessa murphy
8 news now